how do you generate work for
yourself ah yeah well I mean that's the
big question isn't it right like we're
always uh scrambling always hustling you
know trying to get stuff going like uh
if I'm not writing something for someone
else then I'm usually trying to write a
spec you know that um I could hopefully
sell or get set up somewhere um I have a
couple of um companies that uh I'll
sometimes just be like what do you what
do you want what do you looking for you
know and then I'll see if I can create a
need you know for my skills like okay we
want a dog movie I'm like all right well
let me come up with a pitch and I'll
pitch them to see if like if I could
write this in a short amount of time for
you and you have it um wouldn't that be
better than not having it just having
some weird idea about a dog movie right
so I try to look where there's a um a
void right like something that they need
and that I can provide um I am a big
believer in I'm not in acting class
right now but I support people being in
acting class all the time I think that's
a great way to not necessarily get work
but to make contacts in the business you
know everybody hates the idea of
networking it's like I I don't think
about it like that I'm not going to
cocktail parties and walking across the
room and introducing myself bla Weaver
writer director actor you know but it's
like being out and being in people's
face and being like Oh you know who's
great at this is weave and I just saw
him the other night at this thing so I
think being social in this world is
important going to see theater is
important um you know like supporting
your like for instance I have this
amazing cast for this movie Miss
Valentine and uh Mary Lu Henner is in it
and she's doing a play in LA so I'm
going to go see that and uh you know the
other actress has an idea for a movie so
we're going to collaborate on that and
um that's it it's all about surrounding
yourself by people that are doing the
thing that you want to do and seeing if
there's anything you guys can do
together you know and or being one of
the few people that someone thinks of
when they think I need a script or I
need a director or I need somebody for
this part oh you know who would be great
would be blame you know and that's
that's who you want to be you want to be
on the you know top 10 lists of about 50
people and then work just seems to come
your way and sometimes it
doesn't but you know you can only do
what you can do what is the shotgun
approach uh the shotgun approach is uh
just doing all of it uh you know if you
do all of it uh you know there's this
great book uh by Robert Caro three books
actually about LBJ and LBJ running for
Senate and president and you know but
his lb J's thing was if he does
everything he can if he does every idea
if he tries in every single way that he
can to win an election then he can't
lose I don't know if that's true he
didn't lose but like I think of it like
that I think of have I done everything
that I can to um pursue a career in this
business you know am I prepared am I
reaching out to the human beings that I
need to reach out to do I know all of
the skills that I need like you know uh
I write screenplays but uh not too long
ago I wrote a a series outline because
I'd never done it before because that's
something that I needed to have in my
you know uh toolbox right um I acted
I've acted for a long time but like I
hadn't done Shakespeare so I went and
did a Shakespeare play you know it's
like doing everything that you can to
make make yourself better at what you're
trying to do and to do as many things as
you can on the Spectrum you know of
making that uh like I love we've talked
already about like directing producing
writing acting being there understanding
what this person's job is what this
person's job is and then just trying to
take the shotgun approach to me is very
much like the Renaissance person
approach of like I just want to work in
the Arts and am I doing every anything
that I can to to make that happen why do
you think most people will never have a
career in the film industry I mean there
are so many people whose literal job it
is to stop you from having a career in
this industry there are Gatekeepers at
every different aspect at every rung of
the ladder there are people whose
position is to stop people from coming
in um and that's for several different
reasons you know it's like uh our our
unions you know uh we've got a lot of
people in our unions the so we make it
difficult to get into the Union because
then you know we have one more person
who doesn't have insurance but we would
like them to have insurance you know uh
uh the obviously the the the one of the
things that I've come back to several
times in this conversation has been
about who you know how you meet people
how you uh need to hang out and be with
people who are doing the business that
you want to be doing that's how so much
gets done right and those people can
only know so many people and if you just
moved to town and you just graduated
from theater school or you just
graduated film school and you don't know
these people then that's about 90% of
the jobs you're not going to get right
so you have to find how how do I get
those 10% of jobs that are available
that somebody's not just going to say
this is my guy I use my guy every time
this is the girl that I hire every
single time for this position right um
at least that's what I do I love the
Loyalty thing because not just because
I'm helping them I love giving people
that I respect work but I know who what
I'm going to get I know that they're
going to do a level of job that I need
and I appreciate so why go out and get
someone new um so that's another aspect
of it also it takes a lot of time in
order to to meet those people to get in
front of enough people if you're an
actor you know I don't think it's crazy
to say that it takes 10 years before you
actually you know can have a legit
career that um you can continue working
right 10 years is a long time a lot of
people don't have 10 years to not make a
decent wage you know to not have health
insurance to you know have to drive a
not great car because they're living off
of their night job right I patience
um
luck the numerous amount of people who
either because it's their job or because
it's their nature don't want you to win
um there's a lot of that too you know
Petty people all over the world not just
in this business but a lot of them work
here
um so it's it's it's a near
impossibility and that's what makes it
so cool like the cool thing is if you
know everybody could do it they would
that's what makes
just the people who try so special it's
such a special Club of human beings of
people who have like moved to LA or New
York or Austin or Nashville or whatever
in order to pursue something in the
movie world you know whether it's acting
or composing or any of it it's so hard
it's
so Rife with competition and the people
who are the best at this in the world
would say yeah I'll do a score for a
movie why not that sounds like fun even
those guys right like will will will
look at it and be like yeah I'll try
that sure and then you've just bumped
out 200 people who would like to do it
you know what I mean um it's incredibly
competitive but also incredibly
fulfilling and worth the fight you know
um it's uh it's it's worth the struggle
because the struggle itself is part of
an experience
um but yeah I don't know like it works
out for some it doesn't work out for
others but the truth is I feel like the
longer you stick around the the more
chance that you have of emerging because
I've been doing this since I was what 16
15 years old and I still when I go out
uh in La I still see people that I was
in my first acting class with or did my
first job with um I just did this movie
and I cast an actress that I did a
commercial with um 20 years ago 20 years
ago I was playing a teenager and and you
know she was playing a uh a a parking
meter person it was a Ford Focus
commercial but it was just so Random of
like we did a commercial together a
million years ago and that's what's cool
about this business it's a small club
and uh it's not just a small Club of the
people who succeed but of those who
would even try and stick it out for a
little bit so then there still are
Gatekeepers because you hear about with
crowdfunding and and and dslrs and all
oh there's no Gatekeepers now and and
it's all in our hands is that really
true
no I don't think it is I think that
there's I mean we can make stuff right
we we have the ability to make stuff and
that's awesome and that's you know the
crowdfunding and the you know the
inexpensive cameras the phone that I
have that takes a better you know video
than the camera I used for my first
movie you know like all these things are
absolutely true but um you have
Gatekeepers in the realm of taste makers
I guess or
agencies or Studios basically you know
there's always what I always describe it
as is that there's always someone who's
got a leather chair and they have to
earn that leather chair right and
sometimes they're amazing at their job
and sometimes they just tell other
people no and that's why they get their
leather chair because they were able to
shut the doors on upand cominging you
know uh people in all aspects in all
aspects of it um you know you have uh
talented people who won't recommend
other talented people because they don't
want you to know that talented person
that's also a type of a gatekeeper I
feel like um of people who are like you
know throwing the not experienced people
your way instead of like oh here's a
great person that you know is just as
talented as me um but you know and then
you have um casting directors who are
great and casting Associates I I depend
on them on every film but also they want
the people that they know they don't
want new people you know they want the
people that they know that they've built
a relationship with you know so they
don't need another you know uh mid 40s
uh white guy you know they got that
right they've known this guy for 20
years and that's who they have here they
want something else right it's there's a
there's all kinds you don't get to any
kind of level of import success money
without people trying to stop you from
getting there um and just because we can
make movies doesn't mean that we can get
them out into the world the uh the
studio system the streaming platforms
the you know uh anybody they want their
product to be uh the best and special
and the only way to make that is it has
a stamp of approval right this is you
know if if Brad Pit is going to go and
do an indie movie Brad Pit is going to
finance it and you know have the
distribution rights and probably put all
of his buddies in it so it's no longer
an independent film now it has the cast
of Oceans 11 at it right um but yeah he
wouldn't do my movie he would take over
my movie right because that's where the
worth is does that make sense like we
can go off and make something right now
and it could be the greatest something
else that anybody's ever seen But unless
it wins Sundance Toronto South by
Southwest Tribeca you'll never hear from
it again
um there are
other avenues there are other routes to
take but basically if those taste makers
who are also slamming doors in people's
face all the time right if those taste
makers don't say all right you're not
going to be seen by
anyone I think that's a good example of
of
The Gatekeepers that I'm kind of talking
about what do you do when you're stuck
when months have gone by and nothing's
happening
and it happens to everybody you know uh
this uh this business is uh Hills and
Valleys kind of business um I don't know
anybody that's always working I don't
know anybody that's um always you know
getting to be on set and um you know I
I've got a a camera op that I just hired
for this last movie and he had been
working so much that I didn't even think
he'd be available like he's working on
giant films back to back back to back
and uh he called me and he was like you
know I haven't done anything in 4 months
and I'm like wow cuz I thought all the
time he was working but everybody has
these um down times everybody has these
Seasons I like to think that I work and
create when that's happening when I
don't have anybody that's paying me I
like to think that I'm going to write my
spec every you know I'm I'm constantly
complaining that I don't have time to
write a spec because I'm too busy
writing for other people right but the
only way to really make the big sale or
to you know get the work that I want to
be remembered for you know out there is
to write a spec it's just my idea and
then take it to a studio or production
company but the only time to do that is
when the phone's not ringing because you
can't do it when you're working for
somebody else so even in that there is
an opportunity to create and take
advantage of the moment um you it's just
like the the the year I spent uh in uh
the crappy apartment you know it's like
I wasn't acting I wasn't getting paid to
write but I did some of my best work and
it laid the groundwork for the next 10
years because those movies that I wrote
when nobody would talk to me right were
the movies that got made that gave me
the legitimacy to get hired for other
things how hard is it though to to
create this next best thing when the
phone's not ringing and now you're
worried it's the worst okay it's the
worst like you can never come up with it
right it's like you're you're there and
you're like I have the time it's like Co
you know it's like I had nothing but
time to write and I just kept watching
James Bond movies and uh you know just
uh drinking martines was what I did um
but I wasn't writing the Great American
screenplay I wasn't writing that that
project that surely I've just been
waiting to write that's my own and blah
blah blah uh it's hard but you know
that's where it comes back to the
discipline it's like you have to write
even if you're feeling like what you're
writing is crap even if like what you're
you're sitting there with coffee in the
morning and you're just like this is
awful you might have to go through 15 20
100 pages of awful before you get back
to the point of like wait this is what's
good about this I'm scrapping this I'll
do this but you have to keep writing and
that's um that's the biggest lesson for
screenwriters that exists is that once
you get to a certain skill level pretty
much anything you write is going to be
not too bad right even if the story's
stupid even if your character isn't
driven even you know if if it's lacking
all of these giant things I mean have
you seen movies recently right you can
turn on one of those movies that were
just made for Netflix the last three
years and they're lacking giant giant
chunks of stuff that makes movies great
right but they're written uh coherently
and you know somebody knew what they
were doing so it's like even if you're
writing something that's not turning out
the way you want it to and that you
think it's bad it's probably going to be
better or at least as good as most
things out there so at the very least
you've been practicing your skill right
but also you're probably writing
something that you'll be able to tweak
and make better as you go on that's
that's it you just got to work through
it um which is a terrible boring thing
to do but um it's it's it's how I do
it are you able to put fear aside like
okay the world's falling around me you
know I may not be able to pay this next
month but man I feel so inspired right
now let me create this story well that's
my favorite time my favorite time is
where you know uh when I get passionate
about my work and I feel like I'm doing
a good job um when I feel like I'm in my
zone right there's no fear there's
nothing but um excitement of the
challenge coming forth of the your
ability to do it it's excitement and uh
positivity um the rest of the time I'm
racked with fear and insecurities and
you know all of all of the words uh but
you do it knowing that you're going to
intellectually that you're going to get
back to that point of feeling elated
again and uh so that's what you work for
but sometimes you got to take a day and
just be like all right I'm gonna feel
bad today and I'll feel better tomorrow
and also to being flexible within the
industry probably guarantees more work I
hope so I mean that's certainly been my
uh point of view has been trying to do
the Renaissance person version of uh of
this business well you know I started as
an actor as a teen actor I did
commercials I did TV shows I did you
know TV movies and whatnot I did that
cowboy movie and that inspired me to
start writing so I wrote and then all of
a sudden that movie got made and went to
Sundance and so boom I'm a screenwriter
I'm like okay well uh I just started
writing so I could support my acting
career you know I wanted to write a part
from myself right and so I'm just going
to keep doing that I'm going to keep
writing parts that I think actors will
want to play and so um I did that and
the movie got made I did not get along
with the director uh we we did not see
eye to eye on anything
um and so after that movie I'm like well
I'd like to direct you know I never
wanted to direct until I was fighting
with a director you know and then I'm
like okay well this has inspired me to
to to move on to the next thing um so I
tried and now I you know for a long time
I wouldn't take a producer credit
because I wanted to be the artist you
know I'm like no I want to be the the
indie film guy I don't want to be the
suit right and then it took me you know
into my 40s to real Iz that I was
selling myself short because an
experienced producer who has made movies
on a budget is something that people
will hire that's a another you know
Avenue to go down to get work and to
work in this industry so I've started
doing that now which is great and uh I
feel like the more you can do the better
it makes you at everything um every
movie that I direct I feel like makes me
a better writer makes me a better actor
and vice versa you know um so I think
you should do everything you can I don't
know there's no guaranteed formula right
of how it works out sometimes it works
out for somebody that hasn't struggled
at all and sometimes it works out for
somebody who's done everything they
possibly can um and sometimes it doesn't
so there there's no true West when it
comes to figuring that out but I feel
like if you're an artist and your goal
is to live a fulfilling artistic life
then trying to do as much as you can is
the best way towards that and also the
evolution of the suit has changed
because before you know as a gen xer
people incorporate roles were just seen
as like stuffy but now entrepreneurs are
cool and sexy and wow yeah Rockstar like
you know absolutely and it's like
there's a uh I think a respect from the
industry from the money right for those
uh nons suit suits those uh you
entrepreneurial uh producers creators or
whatever who are um cool and they're
tied in with what's happening and what's
now and what's interesting and they're
not all about the bottom line one would
hope